قوات اوكرانيا تبدا الهجوم واشنطن انتظر
نتائج خلال ايام والناتو يتحدى لكريم
ويتفق معك
يصرخ ليعلن حاله التاهب القصوى في انحاء
البلاد فما الذي يجري واوروبا تعلن عجزها
امام اي عدو قوي فلماذا لو كان ذلك العدو
هو بوتا والرئيس الروسي يشتري ودا افريقيا
ويعلن عن مفاجات للافارقه ومصر تاخذ حصه
الاسد من كرم الدب الروسي والقاره السمراء
ترد الجميل بمبادره للازمه الاوكرانيه
الرئيس الاوكراني يوجه طلبا غريبا
للبرازيل والزعيم الكوري يستعرض عضلاته
بمشاركه الروسيه والصينيه فهل هناك امر
يطبخ تحت الطاوله تركيا تعيد لاجئ سوريا
لبلادهم وعصر الاحتباس الحراري ينتهي
ليبدا عصر الغليان والارض
كارثه عظيمه
بوتين يضع يده على القاره السمراء في
العالم اليوم لا صوت يعلو فوق صوت معارك
الامعاء الخاويه وفي افريقيا لا يتوقف
ضجيج تلك الامعاء حيث تكثر المجاعات ولكن
للغرب اذن من طين واخرى من عجين كما يقول
العرب الا ان الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين يرى
ان القاره الافريقيه السمراء
تستحق مزيدا من الاهتمام بوتين كان قد عقد
قمه روسيا افريقيا في مدينه سان بطرسبرج
الروسيه وقال ان الغرب وضع العراقيل امام
صادرات الحبوب الروسيه متعهدا بتقديم
شحنات حبوب مجانيه لست دول في القاره
الافريقيه مشيرا الى ان حجم التبادل
التجاري مع افريقيا قادر ارتفع بنسبه 30%
في العام الحالي تحاول روسيا التوسع في
افريقيا لتغطيه الانسحاب التدريجي لفرنسا
والغرب من القاره السمراء وهناك اعلن
بوتين عن المفاجاه باعلانه ان موسكو قد
قامت بالغاء 20 مليار دولار من الديون
المستحقه لعدد من الدول الافريقيه لتبدا
اليوم من الصفر دون اي ديون فيا لها من
هديه ثمينه حقا هدايا بوتين لم تقتصر على
مسح الديون فقط حيث اعلن الرئيس الروسي ان
روسيا ومصر سوف تطلقان منطقه صناعيه روسيه
في قناه السويس ومن المقرر توزيع البضائع
المنتجه هناك جميع انحاء افريقيا لتشكل
رفضا كبيرا للاقتصاد المصري مهلا مهلا فها
هو بوتين يضيف ان المشاريع المشتركه بين
موسكو والقاهره ضخمه جدا
رعب بناء محطه الطاقه النوويه فهل تتطور
العلاقه ليتم تصنيع الاسلحه الروسيه على
الاراضي المصريه وبرايكم هل تنالوا مصر ما
نالته الجزائر من اسلحه وبما ان افريقيا
قد اخذت تلك الاعطيات من روسيا فكان لابد
ان يرد الافارقه ولو بجزء بسيط ليعبر عن
امتنانهم لموسكو طرحت افريقيا مبادره
لاحلال السلام بين روسيا واوكرانيا تتكون
المبادره من عشر نقاط اساسيه من بينها بدء
المفاوضات وتوفير ضمانات امنيه وضمان حركه
تصدير الحبوب والاسمده فهل تستطيع افريقيا
ان تفعل ما لم يستطع الشرق والغرب فعله
وفي معارك الحبوب ايضا تعمل اوكرانيا
منفرده لتخرج باتفاق مع النيه بعيدا عن
موسكو وهنا اعلنت الخارجيه الاوكرانيه
اتفقت مع حلف الناتو على اتخاذ اجراءات في
منطقه البحر الاسود لكن دون ذكر اي تفاصيل
بهذا الصدد ومن معارك البطون الخاويه الى
المعارك الملتهبه على الاراضي الاوكرانيه
حيث ذكرت صحيفه نيويورك تايمز الامريكيه
ان الهجوم المضاده الرئيسيه للقوات
الاوكرانيه قد بدا وان نتائجه ستظهر بعد
ايام اكثر من ثلاثه اشهر ونحن نتحدث عن
الهجوم المضاد بين منزلنسكي يعلن عن
بدايته اليوم انتشر يا ابني لنكمل واوضحت
الصحيفه ان الهجوم الموسع الحالي يشارك
فيه جنود اوكرانيون تلقوا تدريبات في
الغرب على المعدات العسكريه الغربيه
الحديثه وعلى ذات السياق زعم نائب وزير
الدفاع البريطاني
انه هجوم القوات الاوكرانيه
الغربيون مضيفا ان الهجوم ليس فيلما
هوليوديا ولن تكون هناك لحظه عندما تتحرك
الدبابات وتعزف الموسيقى وتعرض سلسله من
الطلقات العسكريه المذهله ميدانيا اعلن
الرئيس الاوكراني فلادي تسجيل عده ضربات
في البلاد بعد سلسله من الانفجارات
المترتبه عن هجوم ضخم نفذت القوات الروسيه
بصواريخ مجنحه في جميع انحاء اوكرانيا
وقال هناك العديد من الضربات وهناك حطى
مصواريخ يتساقط هذا وتم الاعلان عن حاله
تاهب جوي في جميع انحاء البلاد بينما اكدت
هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه صدق قواتها هجمات
الروسيه بمحيط كوبانسيك بالتزامن مع قصف
روسي ب 49 صاروخا باتجاه مواقع اوكرانيه
واضافت الهيئه ان قوه موسكو اطلقت اكثر من
60 مقذوفا من الرجيمات الصواريخ على
المناطق السكنيه هذا وكانت المندوبيه
البريطانيه في مجلس الامن الدولي بربره
قالت ان روسيا دمرت قيل مخازن الحبوب في
اوديسا وعبر اوكرانيا مؤكده ان لدى لندن
معلومات تشير الى ان روسيا قد تهاجم السفن
المدنيه في البحر الاسود وهناك اقر الجيش
الاوكراني بان روسيا تحصل جميع الموانئ
تقريبا مشيرا الى انه غير قادر على
التصدير الضربات الروسيه على منشات الحبوب
ليوجه جيليسك طلبا غريبا للبرازيل باعلانه
انه يحتاج الى مساعده رئيس البرازيل
لكي يجمع قاده امريكا اللاتينيه ويتواصل
مع السلطات للحصول على دعم سياسي واعترف
بانه لا يتوقع امدادات اسلحه بلا البرازيل
ومن امريكا اللاتينيه نعود نحو اوروبا حيث
اكد رئيس مجمع غين ميتال للصناعات
العسكريه في المانيا ارمين بابيرغار ان
بلاده هو دول اوروبا ستجد صعوبه بالغه في
الدفاع عن نفسها في حال مهاجمتها من عدو
قوي واشار الى ان 100 مليار يورو التي
السلطات الالمانيه لتحديث قواتها العسكريه
لن تكون كافيه لاعاده تجهيز الجيش وها هي
بوصله الاحداث تضعنا امام اغرب اخبارنا
اليوم حيث مارس السفير الروسي في العراق
البروسكوستراشيا الطقوس الشيعيه الى جانب
المئات من الشيعه بمناسبه ذكرى عاشوراء
الاحداث والتطورات بعد ترحيب حار استقبلت
به كوريا الشماليه الضيفها وزير الدفاع
الروسي
حضر الزعيم الكوري الشمالي كيم جونغ اون
وشويجو وممثل صيني عرضا فنيا وعسكريا اقيم
بمناسبه الذكرى السبعين لانتهاء الحرب
الكوريه فاي رساله يرغب هؤلاء الحلفاء في
ايصالها الى واشنطن من خلال هذا التعاون
اعلن الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان ان
تركيا تخطط لضمان عوده حوالي مليون لاجئ
من اراضيها الى سوريا واعلن اردوغان في
وقت سابق ان تركيا وقطر تنفذان مشروعا
لبناء نحو مليون منزل في شمال سوريا
للاجئين العائدين الى وطنهم اكد الامين
العام للامم المتحده انطونيو غوترش ان عصر
الاحتباس الحراري انتهى مضيفا الى ان عصر
الغليان العالمي بدا على كوكب الارض ولا
في شهر يوليو الجاري هو اكثر شهر سخونه
مسجل على الاطلاق